jennifer lopez is sharing details about
ben affleck's proposal following new
details et is learning including how
quote jyn's family is so thrilled ben is
about to become part of the family i'm
gonna give it away but it has a very
good ending
lopez breaks the moment down in her
newsletter on the jlo also sharing this
video message directed by her
husband-to-be
feeling so lucky it's not often you get
a
second chance at true love
we feel very lucky
the singer says affleck popped the
question during an intimate moment in
the bath it was totally unexpected
my love came in then came in and got
down on one knee and he said some things
that i'll never forget
and he pulled down a ring
and he said will you marry me
and it was
the most perfect moment
and he said it's a green diamond
my favorite color and who else loves
that rock that she's got the couple's
children a source tells e.t quote the
kids are all very excited and have been
telling her how pretty and huge the ring
is
in fact the engagement will be a start
to finish family affair i'm ready i'm
excited about it the source goes on to
reveal quote jen definitely wants a
wedding and wants to share the moment in
a bigger way
she loves the idea of marrying the love
of her life and then partying after with
their family and friends the source also
says quote ben had been telling his
friends he was going to propose for a
while so no one was surprised and we can
only assume matt damon was part of the
combo jayla won't just leave me alone
stop it
uh that was great
it's it's wonderful and uh i'm i'm just
happy to see uh see my friend really
happy okay but back to that engagement
ring
[Music]
lopez first announced the happy news in
her newsletter last week it's also my
lucky color
obviously it'll be my lucky color
forever now lopez explains the green
engagement ring is a full circle moment
as it channels her ever so iconic
versace dress tell me first off with
this outfit versace i saw donatello with
it and i had to have it for the grammy
she writes quote i've realized there are
many moments in my life where amazing
things happened when i was wearing green
it may be a coincidence maybe not
but as i took a better look i realized
there are no coincidences
yay
going to the chat
[Music]